COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some VR expert with
their disk performance.
Does this VR headset make
my performance look awesome?
Stay tuned to find out.
VR Ignition is a
company specializing
in the processing of content
for VR and AR applications.
Their product can scale to
handle massive point clouds
across thousands of CPUs using
the Google Cloud Platform
and, due to the nature
of their algorithms,
had a large need for
local SSDs to handle
their out-of-core algorithms.
However, they were
confused, because they
weren't getting the
type of read performance
they were expecting from
these high performance disks.
I'll spare you some of
the debugging details,
but it turned out
that the problem
was with their disk interface.
See, for local SSDs, there's
two primary interfaces--
SCSI and NVMe.
SCSI, of course, we've
all seen for years now
and is the default for most disk
interfaces in our data centers.
NVMe, however, is the new
kid on the block designed
with modern technologies in mind
to provide higher performance.
For example, whereas SCSI
has one queue for commands,
NVMe is designed to have
up to 64,000 queues.
Moreover, each of those queues
can in turn have up to 64,000
commands simultaneously.
Now, you can switch what
interface your machine uses
at creation time
by passing along
the interface tag to
the local SSD param,
and to show the
performance difference,
we can see the two head-to-head.
We clearly see the NVMe has
an advantage with respect
to read performance
and a slight advantage
over write performance,
but here's the catch.
In order to use NVMe, you
have to have a disk image that
supports it, and
this was the thing
that was hurting VR Ignition.
Firstly, they weren't
setting the flag.
And secondly, they weren't using
a custom image for their builds
that didn't have NVMe support.
Thankfully, after a decent
amount of technical discussion,
they were able to move to a
public image that was already
optimized for NVMe
which let them get
the big boost in performance.
If you'd like to know
more about this topic,
check out the article
linked in the description
below, and don't forget to
check out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]